لدينا الآن مصطلح في مستشفى الشفاء
يسمى الطفل الجريح دون وجود أسرة على قيد الحياة
لتعيين أكثر من 50 طفلًا تم
انتشالهم من تحت الأنقاض
بمفردهم وأصيبوا بجروح
ويتلقون العلاج في المستشفى 2000
طفل قتلوا في أقل من 16 عامًا  أيام وبالنسبة
لنظام تبلغ سعته الإجمالية
2500 سرير قبل
بدء الحرب، فنحن ننتظر فقط
نفاد الكهرباء مع الوقود
وبعد ذلك سيكون ذلك بمثابة الموت
للنظام الصحي و
بدون بدون كهرباء،
تعلم أن هذا المستشفى سيكون مجرد
مقبرة جماعية، ولا يوجد ما يمكن فعله
لهؤلاء الجرحى، فالنظام
يتفكك وبدون وقف إطلاق النار
وممر إنساني لا يمثل رمزًا 14
15 20 شاحنة لمليونين وربع
مليون شخص ولكن  ممر إنساني حقيقي
يسمح بإجلاء
هؤلاء الجرحى ويسمح
بدخول المساعدات الإنسانية والفرق الطبية
دون ذلك، ستكون هناك
كارثة أكبر من تلك
الموجودة بالفعل هنا، كل شيء قد
نفد بالفعل، والأهم من ذلك
أننا  لقد نفدت المساحة، فالمستشفى الذي
كان يتسع لما بين 550 و700
سرير يضم الآن 700 مريض في
مراتب في الممرات في
طوابق قسم الطوارئ
والوضع مأساوي ونحن في النهاية فقط
تظهر لقطات CNN بدون طيار دمارًا
واسع النطاق في غزة بينما
توسع إسرائيل هجومها ضد
حماس،
هذه هي مدينة الساه في وسط [
موسيقى]
غزة، الحصار الإسرائيلي والقصف شبه المستمر
لغزة ردًا على
القتل والاختطاف في 7 أكتوبر
أدى هياج حماس إلى تسوية
أحياء بأكملها بالأرض، بما في ذلك المدارس
والمساجد، ودمر نظام
الرعاية الصحية غير الكافي بالفعل
وفقًا
لوزارة الصحة الفلسطينية التي تسيطر عليها حماس، وقد
مات ما لا يقل عن 5087 شخصًا في غزة منذ 7
أكتوبر [
موسيقى]